cauchemar à melbourne pour l'open
d'australie quatre cas de co vite sont
détectés à bord de deux avions
transportant les plus grands joueurs de
tennis du monde
imposant ainsi une stricte quarantaine à
47 athlètes ils sont furieux et ils
doivent se contenter d'un entraînement
de chambre d'hôtel tout ceci ne serait
pas arrivé si cette compagnie qatar
airways s'était assuré que tous les
passagers avaient bien été déclarés
négatifs à l'aco vide et si elle avait
déjà mis en place en application de
passeport santé le iata parce qu'elle
est en train d'expérimenter ce passeport
santé est une des clés de la reprise de
l'industrie dont la situation est
catastrophique pour nous on n'a jamais
connu ça l'iata l'association
internationale des transporteurs aériens
veut aider à supprimer les quarantaine
imposée aux voyageurs ou les aides à
l'ouverture des frontières de la du
redémarrage des voyages et donc c'est
que on n'a pas su de contrôle chez
[Musique]
british airways offre dès cette semaine
l'application very fly compatible avec
celle de l'iata qui permet aux passagers
au lieu d'un long processus de contrôle
au départ d'avoir dans son appareil
mobile
la preuve de son test négatif et des
rendez-vous de tests au deuxième et
huitième jour de son arrivée en grande
bretagne ce qui devrait lui permettre
d'éviter la quarantaine copa compagnie
panaméenne qui dessert toute l'amérique
va lancer en mars son application il ya
pas parce que bientôt lufthansa et
united des partenaires de star alliance
ce qui veut dire qu'air canada devrait
suivre c'est beau en théorique mais en
pratique le problème c'est c'est que si
on utilise passeportsante dans sa
version numérique
ce qui est compliqué c'est de savoir la
validité et la pertinence donc des
documents numériques
il faut avoir confiance en des
laboratoires reconnus être à l'abri des
faux et être sûr de la confidentialité
des données et surtout avoir la
confiance et la collaboration des
gouvernements ce qui dans les
circonstances actuelles au canada par
exemple n'est pas évident quand on
regarde un décor à l'eau le plus fermé
des sons tout ce qui touche le transport
aérien où il se passera rien on est à
partir desquels du très strict
quand vous avez par exemple si vous
hésitez passeport canada et que le
canada ne change pas ses règles en
matière de 14 jours de confinement
oui mais tellement forte qu'elle vaccin
n'apporte pas ce serait leur estomac et
puis voilà ça devient un obstacle par
rapport à ça pourtant les compagnies
aériennes gère très bien les exigences
de visa électronique du canada pour la
plupart des visiteurs étrangers
la vae l'autorisation de voyage
électronique
vous ne pouvez pas entrer dans un pays
comme la bolivie par exemple sans avoir
votre certificat de vaccination contre
la fièvre jaune donc la coordination est
possible et elle devrait devenir
nécessaire cette pandémie nous a montré
que ce n'est pas la première ni la
dernière pandémie
le passeport santé aura peut être du mal
à s'imposer avant la fin de la pandémie
mais il a probablement de l'avenir si la
confiance règne
pourquoi pas un passeport santé et
sécurité dans les avions et surtout dans
les aéroports ce qui faciliterait une
bonne foi les voyages pour tous au lieu
de les compliquer à chaque crise
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal